From poverty in a segregated rural town in the southern state of Arkansas,...
...Maya Angelou rose to become one of the nation's most well-known authors,...
...poets and activists for civil rights.
She tells of a youth filled with pain and injustice in her 1969 memoir,...
..."I Know Why the Caged Bird Sings."
Her early life was so filled with trauma,...
...the author said, she stopped speaking for more than five years.
She started speaking again after she began writing poetry.
Later, she wrote essays, plays and screenplays, creating a body of work...
...that inspired students and presidents.
In 1993, she read one of her poems at President Bill Clinton's inauguration.
Lift up your eyes upon this day breaking for you.
Give birth again to the dream.
Women, children, men, take it into the palms of your hand.
President Barack Obama awarded Angelou the Presidential Medal of Freedom in 2010...
...for creating soaring poetry and towering prose that helped raise the conscience of a nation.
The White House also praised her mastery of a range of art forms.
Angelou worked as a dancer and actress...
...and became renowned for the power of a voice she once refused to use.
She became a powerful voice for civil rights...
...and for those struggling to reach their full potential.
Although she never went to college, Angelou received more than 30 honorary degrees...
...and taught at Wake Forest University in North Carolina for three decades.
In confirming her death, the university described her as a "national treasure"...
...whose life in teaching inspired millions around the world.
Mary Alice Salinas, VOA News, Washington.